I was gonna ask it's just like an
interesting area for me like you're back
home in st. Louis right and you are you
just you've talked to me in the past
about how maybe you weren't confident
with guys or guys didn't notice you back
then now you're back yeah and you've had
all this success and you're back in your
hometown where you grew up and you're
interested in dating or socially in
distance yeah is there are you trying to
like look through like guys that maybe
didn't pay attention to you oh yeah I
got my yearbooks out for sure high
school but now it's sort of it's Nikki's
revenge you'd come back yeah so what's
that like I I did I have I've been going
through my yearbooks and just kind of
flipping through seeing if I may be
overlooked someone trying to see with oh
maybe this guy what would he look like
without acne and maybe with some crow's
feet and a you know pill problem just
classic st. Louis and you know there I
but look if they're all married you know
for now I think when this quarantine
lets up there's gonna be a lot of single
guys out there but it's really gonna
kill it yeah I can't wait but yeah there
there has been parts of me that want to
go back and be like would you consider
me now you know just to a guy in high
school just be like hey doctor Havener
remember me I'm legal now just different
administrators he's like your to legal
yeah but it's just there's nowhere to go
there's nothing to do there's nowhere to
go with any of these people I'm just i
the it's weird how like my standards for
men have now changed I used to want a
guy that like was very handsome and
maybe you know successful a blue
checkmark on Instagram and now I'm just
looking for a guy with like a Costco
card and who could maybe work a crossbow
I just it's the other day I was at the
grocery store and the guy just bagging
my groceries I like got a little bit
turned on just because I'm just like
just a man just a straight a man other
than my dad I was like the way
he like bag to my cauliflower I was like
he'd be like a good dad
like there's that's what I'm starting if
everything's changed for me I'm glad I
needed to like lower my expectations I
think yeah I mean that was first of all
that may be the guy for you because
you're you know it's you're seeing a man
in a good light when you're seeing him
bagging groceries he's he's literally
beating you he's putting nutrition and
food yeah you're paying for it but in
terms of like caveman stuff it's sexy
it's really seen guys be like safe and
wear gloves and face masks I'm just like
in almost keeping their distance from me
it makes me like them more I'm like I'll
take a bandana to clean up on aisle
myself like it's it's pretty arousing
just to see guys having like basic
safety precautions now yeah it's it's
life has just changed so much I feel
like I'm just walking around my parents
house like I'm filming the first half of
a cymbalta ad you know before she asked
her doctor for help just like sweatpants
limp hair shivering like staring outside
of windows being like I used to have fun
like just things are just so different
now my spray tan is gone I don't I have
only just for the past 10 years of my
life just been reapplying spray tans
I don't know if you've ever done a spray
tan never have no it takes your white
privilege to a new level to be slightly
tanner but I'm back to like this is my
normal skin color and apparently I'm not
Guatemalan I didn't know that until it
came off I I didn't need a 23andme a
report I just needed a loofah I guess it
just looked great I think you look
really great
I think this is gonna be good for women
and for everyone just we're gonna remind
ourselves what it we look like again I'm
just getting away from beauty I mean I
got dolled up for this cuz it's TV and
it really matters to me but in terms of
just living my life I just I don't know
there's there's times where an
I think a lot of women are going through
this I just want to shave my head like I
just went on just just get I don't want
to have to care about anything anymore
cuz it's just about survival and then I
was like why do I want to shave my head
when I have it hasn't even occurred to
me to shave my legs even once during
this like maybe give those a world-first
it might be weird to look like she's an
eight O'Connor up here and Bob Ross down
here but going on it's just it's such a
weird time my mom was telling me the
other day about my cousin is like she
was like oh he broke up with his
girlfriend and you know just finished
school and I was just like what's his
story like I got like almost interested
in my cousin because I'm so just at
least that's at least he's I could see
there's a way I could see him maybe and
convince my parents I need to see my
cousin and I didn't even occur to me
that he was my cousin and that was
inappropriate my first thought was like
oh no he's too young
that was my first it's a real thought I
out I was like oh he's so cute
yeah yeah the young and and too young is
a thing because there I'm about to be 36
and I'm getting approached by a lot of
guys like younger dudes that are like
you could teach me a thing or two people
think I'm like very exceptionally
experienced and just this whole thing of
like teach me and I'm like algebra like
what do you what do I get the summers
off I just I don't I need to be taught
still